-Our first guest tonight
is a three-time
Grammy Award-winning musician
who's celebrating
the 10th anniversary
of his mixtape "Acid Rap."
He's also a coach
on "The Voice,"
which airs Mondays
at 8:00 on NBC.
Please welcome to the show
Chance the Rapper, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome.
I'm so happy to have you.
-I'm happy to finally
be here, man.
-It's a thrill for me.
This is crazy.
I can't believe this has been
10 years since you put this out.
Now, of course, I realize
it's only been eight years
since I was hip to it 'cause
I'm, like, a nerd, you know?
Not a nerd.
I'm, like, a loser.
Like, I always find out about
cool music like two years later.
So two years from now,
I'm gonna celebrate
my 10th anniversary.
-That's sick, dude.
-But this is sort of the album
that changed everything.
Again, you're self-releasing it,
so you're doing it
independently.
But after this, you start
playing real big shows.
-Yeah.
-Which is nuts.
Did you ever -- When you're
going out and making this music
and sort of releasing it
by yourself,
did you ever think it was
gonna lead to something
that was not even international,
but just nationwide?
-Yeah, I was like -- I was --
-Good.
Got to believe it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I -- Yeah, no,
I just always wanted to --
I was always making music
and performing
and doing talent shows
since I was a little kid.
So, like, when I decided
to become a rapper,
I was always hoping
that it would be successful.
I didn't really have
a plan B or anything,
but, yeah, no,
the shows just kept --
-What were the --
But what were the --
Like, right before you start
doing your big tour,
what were the sort of local
shows you were doing in Chicago?
Where were the venues?
-It was kind of any stage
I could get on.
I played -- I played
Reggies' Rock Club
and Lincoln Hall in Chicago.
I used to do shows at,
like, the --
at the library if I could.
Man, literally anywhere.
I performed at my aunt's breast
cancer awareness rally once.
They liked it.
It was dope.
-They did alright?
-Yeah.
-Probably a slightly
different crowd
than you were used to
at the time.
Is it true that you
played a few,
like, high school parking lots
that had to get shut down?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I used to literally set up
wherever I could,
and I'd come out with, like --
I'd have posters that I'd print
with this, like,
album cover on it
and, like, have, like,
I don't know, T-shirts and stuff
and try and, like, sling them
in the parking lots
after school
at different high schools.
And then, like you said,
I would get shut down.
-Was it good for your reputation
when it would get shut down?
-Yeah, you know, actually,
that builds, like, some sort of,
like, you know,
mystique around it.
You got to get there
before the cops come.
You know what I mean?
-I would think
that's very helpful, as well.
Did you ever --
I mean, Chance the Rapper,
first of all, it's a great name
because it's very on the nose.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-No confusion about it.
But I have to imagine you had
some other options early on.
-Oh, yeah, well, I had a name
when I was in eighth grade.
I was --
I went by Tony Jizzle.
-Okay.
Maybe a wise choice
to say goodbye to Mr. Jizzle.
-No, I'm glad that that part
of my life is over with.
Very much so an eighth-grade
kind of name, yeah.
-You're going out, you know,
sort of to celebrate
this anniversary.
And you have a couple new shows.
Can you announce
a couple new locations?
-I'm glad that we could
announce it here.
Yeah, so we just --
In celebration
of the 10th-year anniversary,
we put up tickets on sale
for a Chicago show
at the United Center,
and they sold out immediately.
So by popular demand,
I decided to add two more shows,
one in Los Angeles and another
one here in New York City.
-Alright, that's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You had -- You mentioned
Madison Square Garden.
And this is -- I'm sorry, you
mentioned the United Center.
But Madison Square Garden
once put you up on-screen.
They got a little bit
of grief for this,
because if you look
at the lower third
of what they --
how they described you.
Your name is Chance the Rapper.
And then underneath,
they wrote "rapper."
-Yeah.
-And then you reached out
and you said, "In the future,
the titles 'Father' and 'Zaddy'
are both acceptable."
-Oh!
-That was nice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now -- Then you go back.
You're at the United Center.
And now it's your
hometown venue, right?
And, I mean,
obviously they heard you.
And I think it's very nice.
They put you up
Chance the Rapper, father/zaddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-Mid-nacho chip, too.
I'm eating.
-Yeah, you never know
when they're gonna
throw you up on the screen.
So -- And now you are a dad.
You got two girls.
-I got two beautiful girls.
-And that's very exciting.
How are they --
Yours are about the same ages
as mine.
And I'm wondering --
I think kids are obviously
maybe more drawn to music
than late-night television.
Do they have any engagement
with your work?
Do they know your songs?
Do they like any of it?
-Yeah, they do like my music.
They -- They're really --
They're more into, like,
Peppa Pig
and their contemporaries.
Like, they're more,
like, into that.
But, like, I have a few songs
that they'll listen to.
They like a song called
"Let's Go on the Run" a lot.
-That's a good song for kids.
That's got some --
Yeah, that's a very sweet song.
-I got to be careful when I'm
picking my songs for my kids.
But they like --
-Yeah, that's very funny
that I could see, you know --
I know your work enough to know
there are some songs
where you'd be like,
"Do not listen
to that song by Daddy."
-I didn't mean this.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't mean this at all.
No, yeah, no, it's cool.
But yeah.
-Would you ever think -- I mean,
in a desperate attempt
to gain their affection,
would you do a collaboration
with Peppa?
[ Laughter ]
-Out of my own desperation,
I'd do a track with Peppa.
Like, if Peppa --
if you're listening right now,
like, I'm trying to work
or at least get some autographs
for my kids.
Shout-out to Peppa Pig.
-Shout-out to Peppa Pig.
-And the Baby Shark also.
-Oh, Baby Shark.
You'd work with Baby Shark?
-I would in a heartbeat.
Is this my opportunity
to get these features?
Baby Shark.
-Any fictional characters. Yeah.
-Thank you, man,
for giving me this spot.
-I want to ask you
about "The Voice."
We're gonna be right back with
more from Chance the Rapper.